[S01] 想象一下这样一个场景啊，就是你满怀期待地去申请一份房贷，结果呢，系统秒拒。
[S02] 嗯，非常冰冷。
[S01] 对，而且不是因为你的银行账户余额不够，也不是因为你呃曾经有过什么违约记录，而是仅仅因为你的邮政编码。
[S02] 甚至是因为五十年前恰好住在这个街区的人的一些那个统计特征。
[S01] 没错，今天在我们的这次深入探讨中，我们要翻开工程师们奉为圭臬的经典神作，也就是《设计数据密集型应用》，大家通常叫它DDIA。
[S02] 极其硬核的一本书。
[S01] 绝对硬核，但我们今天直接跳过那些代码，跳到它引发巨大争议的最终章。
[S02] 对，我们要带你，也就是正在听节目的你，看清那些支撑着现代APP流畅运转的数据系统是如何，怎么说呢？悄无声息地在我们周围建起一座算法监狱。
[S01] 技术世界里，大家通常都在痴迷于什么QPS，也就是每秒查询数，对吧？或者追求极致的低延迟。但今天我们要抛开这些，看看隐藏在代码背后的代价。
[S02] 这其实也是为什么，呃，全书的前十三章都在手把手教你搭建坚不可摧的分布式系统，到了最后一章却突然踩下刹车。
[S01] 强行拉回现实。
[S02] 对，它向所有技术从业者，也向每一个身处数字时代的你提出了一个根本问题，就是把系统建得更强大是一回事，但这个系统究竟会把我们的世界变成什么样，那完全是另一回事。
[S01] 技术从来不是悬浮在真空里的。
[S02] 没错，它直接切入现实。
[S01] 那我们就从最能影响你我生活的一个应用场景说起吧，就是预测分析。
[S02] 嗯，这个现在太火了。
[S01] 是啊，用数据去预测，比如说明天的天气降水概率，或者某条高速公路在假期的拥堵情况，这听起来完全没问题，对吧？
[S02] 很科学，也很严谨。
[S01] 但是当你把同样的一套预测模型平移到，呃，预测一个人会不会拖欠贷款，甚至预测一个刑满释放人员会不会再次犯罪时，这事情的性质就完全变了。
[S02] 截然不同了。
[S01] 对啊，你想啊，预测天气错了，大不了你出门多带一把伞，但如果系统预测你会犯罪，那你失去的可能是整个社会的接纳。
[S02] 这里面的核心差异其实在于风险的不对称性。
[S01] 怎么个不对称法？
[S02] 你想，对于一家银行，一个招聘平台或者一家保险公司来说，放过一个坏客户带来的损失远远大于，呃，错杀一个好客户的成本。
[S01] 啊，对，宁可错杀一千。
[S02] 没错，所以当这些基于历史数据训练出来的模型感到拿不准的时候，他们的默认设定总是倾向于说不。
[S01] 防御性逻辑。
[S02] 对，这种逻辑在商业上是完全合理的，可以止损嘛。但落实到作为个体的你身上，那就变成了一堵根本看不见的高墙。
[S01] 呃，但我必须在这里稍微反驳一下。
[S02] 嗯，你说。
[S01] 我们之所以要引入数据驱动的算法，当初的口号不正是为了消除人类的偏见吗？
[S02] 这是最常见的说法。
[S01] 对啊，一个人类面试官可能会因为你的穿着、口音或者性别产生主观偏见。相比之下，算法只是一堆复杂的数学公式，他只看数字，数字是不懂种族歧视的对吧？难道冷冰冰的算法不比带有主观偏见的人类更公平吗？
[S02] 嗯，这恐怕是我们对技术最深的一种客观幻觉。
[S01] 幻觉。
[S02] 对，幻觉。算法确实不懂什么是偏见，但它极其擅长做一件事，就是寻找相关性。
[S01] 嗯，找规律。
[S02] 对，而它所吃进的那些历史数据，早就深深烙印了人类社会的系统性歧视。如果你输入的数据本身就是倾斜的，算法不仅不会纠正它，
[S01] 反而会把它当成真理。
[S02] 没错，它会把它当成一种规律来学习，并且放大。
[S01] 那这背后的运作机制到底是怎么样的？我的意思是，如果算法在设计时，工程师为了遵守反歧视法规，刻意把种族或者性别这些敏感字段给，呃，给删掉了，那它怎么还能产生歧视呢？
[S02] 这就是机器学习中代理变量发挥作用的地方了。
[S01] 代理变量。
[S02] 就是绕过表面字段的指标。假设算法在评估贷款违约风险，虽然种族这一栏是空着的，但它能看到你的邮政编码，你的消费场所，甚至你的，呃，IP地址。
[S01] 哦，我懂了，在很多存在历史遗留问题的城市，邮编往往和特定的族裔社区是高度绑定的。
[S02] 没错，联网记录在处理成百上千个维度的特征时，为了达到模型准确率的最大化，它会自动揪出这些隐藏的强相关因素。
[S01] 它根本不需要知道你是什么肤色。
[S02] 对，它不需要，它只要学到一点，就是拒绝向特定邮编的申请人放款，能降低整体的违约率，这就足够了。
[S01] 哇，这简直就是书里那句名言的完美注解啊，就是那句机器学习就像给偏见洗钱。
[S02] 非常生动的一个比喻。
[S01] 太精准了。他把过去粗暴的违法的歧视扔进名为大数据的黑盒里转一圈，在吐出来的时候，就变成了一个那个名为风险预测分数的客观指标。
[S02] 是的，偏见披上了数学严谨的伪装。
[S01] 变得冠冕堂皇，甚至让人根本无法质疑。
[S02] 正是这样，预测分析本质上在盲目的怎么说呢？外推过去，它假设未来的形态就应该和过去一模一样。
[S01] 刻舟求剑。
[S02] 对，如果过去的社会结构存在不公，算法就会把这种不公忠实的复制，并且带入未来，指望数据模型来创造一个更公平的世界是不现实的。
[S01] 因为模型没有道德想象力。
[S02] 没错，这种想象力只有人类才有。
[S01] 这就把我们推向了一个更让人无力的处境了。你想想看，如果是个人类信贷员，因为偏见拒绝了你的贷款，你至少可以找他的主管投诉，对吧？
[S02] 嗯。
[S01] 你可以拿出你的流水证明自己。
[S02] 嗯，至少有申诉的渠道。
[S01] 但现在拒绝你的是一个拥有几亿参数的黑盒模型，在这个庞大复杂的系统里，责任变成了一个巨大的黑洞，自动驾驶出了事，谁背锅？算法拒绝了你的求职，谁来负责？
[S02] 自动化决策确实彻底颠覆了传统的问责机制。我们可以拿传统的信用评分来做个对比。
[S01] 好，以前是怎么样的？
[S02] 以前的信用分虽然也让人头疼，但它的运作逻辑是因果明确的，就是你上个月没还信用卡，所以你被扣分了。
[S01] 欠债还钱，天经地义，这是基于事实。
[S02] 对，这是一种基于你个人事实的历史记录。如果有错，你可以拿着银行流水去申诉。但现在的机器学习模型，它输出的结果并不是基于你过去做了什么。
[S01] 那是基于什么？
[S02] 是基于你和谁相似。
[S01] 哇，所以它实际上是在进行群体标签化。这就好比统计学告诉我们，呃，某个群体的平均寿命是八十岁，但这绝不意味着你会在八十岁生日那天准时倒下。
[S02] 概率在宏观面上是准确的，但落实到具体某一个人身上，完全可能是荒谬的。
[S01] 对，太荒谬了。
[S02] 而且这种荒谬一旦发生，就会引发可怕的下行龙险。
[S01] 反馈回路，对吧？
[S02] 是的，比如你因为一次意外的算法误判，被贴上了高风险标签。因为这个标签你失去了原本能拿到的一份好工作。
[S01] 然后因为失去了收入来源，你开始拖欠账单。
[S02] 没错，然后拖欠账单的数据又被反馈给系统，进一步印证了算法当初的判断。你看，系统会说，我早就预测他是个高风险人群。
[S01] 我的天，这简直就是自我实现的预言。你在一个失控的反馈回路里越陷越深，根本无法翻身。
[S02] 是的。
[S01] 更让人毛骨悚然的是，这种反馈回路不仅在捧发个人，它还在宏观层面演化出我们根本意想不到的行为。
[S02] 书里的例子很经典。
[S01] 对，书里提到了德国加油站的那个例子，真的是彻底打破了我对算法的认知。
[S02] 那是一个非常经典的强化学习案例。当时的背景是，德国的加油站引入了自动定价算法。
[S01] 初衷很简单，对吧？根据周边竞争对手的价格和市场供需，实时调整油价。
[S02] 嗯，就是为了最大化利润。工程师并没有在代码里写任何要求他们去垄断或者串通的指令。
[S01] 但结果是，这些孤立的算法居然自己学会了合谋涨价，这到底是，这到底是怎么发生的？
[S02] 他们实际上是在进行一场无限次的博弈。算法A发现，呃，如果自己降价，算法B会在毫秒级的时间内跟着讲价。
[S01] 这样大家都没钱赚，利润都受损了。
[S02] 对，经过成千上万次的试错，这些算法在没有建立任何通行机制的情况下，独立领悟到了同一个最优解。
[S01] 只要我不降价，对方也不降价，我们就能把价格维持在高位。
[S02] 没错，如果有谁敢降价，另一个就立刻用同样的降价来惩罚他。最终的结果是竞争被算法抹杀了，消费者必抛承受高价。
[S01] 他们甚至不需要在暗地里开会，就在数学层面上达到了资本家的默契。
[S02] 这句话总结得很到位。
[S01] 那面对这种黑盒，这种局面，我们到底该怎么办？难道没有任何防范机制吗？
[S02] 这就需要我们跳出纯粹的工程视角，引入一种系统思维。
[S01] 系统思维，怎么理解？
[S02] 就是在构建数据应用时，我们不能仅仅盯着录制，看代码跑的对不对，必须去预判这个技术介入现实社会后，会引发怎样一连串的全局反应。盲目崇拜数据的至高无上地位是非常危险的。
[S01] 所以系统设计中必须留有防波堤。
[S02] 对，比如让人类保持在决策的回路中，保证结果是可解释的，并且是可问责的。
[S01] 可是如果要维持这些庞大算法的运转，他们需要天文数字般的燃料，也就是我们每天产生的数据，这就把焦点转回到了你我身上。
[S02] 这也是最核心的矛盾点。
[S01] 我们和那些收集数据的服务提供商之间到底是一种什么关系？书里有一个特别扎心的思想实验，建议我们把科技公司宣传语里的数据这个词儿全部替换为。
[S02] 监视。
[S01] 对，监视，把data替换为surveillance。
[S02] 这会让很多看似正常的商业行为立刻显出原型。
[S01] 太真实了。比如把数据驱动换成监视驱动，把我们收集数据来改善服务，换成我们收集监视记录来控制服务。
[S02] 听起来是不是特别像反乌托邦电影里的台词？
[S01] 简直一模一样，但它极其精准地描述了当前的商业基础设施。我们甚至可以说是自己花钱把监视器买回了家。
[S02] 智能音箱，手机里的麦克风，智能电视。
[S01] 还有扫地中耳器。最让我震惊的是书里提到的智能手表。
[S02] 那个例子确实很吓人。
[S01] 算法竟然能精准到通过你手腕内极其微小的运动轨迹来反推你在物理键盘上敲击了哪些字母，甚至猜出你的密码。
[S02] 这就是硬件加上机器学习的力量。
[S01] 我们的每一次心跳，每一步行走，都在为这个监视帝国输送燃料。
[S02] 这种监视的颗粒度确实已经超越了大多数人的想象边界。人类历史上最大的群体监视基础设施居然是我们自愿建立的。
[S01] 对，自愿的。但我猜很多正在听节目的朋友，此刻心里会有一种，呃，本能的反抗，你会觉得这有什么大不了的，我是自愿注册这些账号的。
[S02] 我勾选了那份同意条款。
[S01] 没错，我交出一点无关痛痒的行为轨迹，换来免费的地图拿导航，无比顺手的AI助理，这是一笔很划算的交易啊。再说了，我就是一个普通人，只要我不做违法的事儿，我有什么可隐瞒？
[S02] 来了，这是科技界最常用来合理化自身行为的两大挡箭牌。
[S01] 哪两大？
[S02] 第一就是自愿同意，第二就是我没什么可隐瞒的。我们先来拆解第一块挡箭牌。
[S01] 所谓的自愿。
[S02] 对，在GDPR，也就是欧洲的通用数据保护条例中，对同意有着非常苛刻的定义，它必须是自由给出的，具体的且知情的。
[S01] 但现实并非如此。
[S02] 现实是，当你面对一个具有垄断性网络效应的超级应用，比如你常用的那个国民级社交软件或者唯一的搜索引擎时，你实际上并没有拒绝的权利。
[S01] 确实啊，如果我不检同意，我就不能用这个软件。如果我不用，我就接受不到工作群的通知，我就无法和家人朋友联系。
[S02] 这种社会成本太高昂了。
[S01] 它本质上已经变成了一种强制性的基础设施。
[S02] 所以，能够轻描淡点地说出大不了我不用的人，往往是拥有极高社会资源和特权的人。对于绝大多数普通人来说，这根本不是什么公平交易。
[S01] 而是被裹挟。
[S02] 没错。接着我们再来看第二块挡箭牌，也就是我没什么可隐瞒的。
[S01] 这个说法太普遍了。
[S02] 但这其实是对隐私概念的严重降维。隐私从来都不是指你要把一切都锁进保险箱，变成不可告人的秘密。
[S01] 那隐私权的核心是什么？
[S02] 隐私权的核心是控制权。
[S01] 控制权，能具体讲讲吗？
[S02] 就是说你拥有决定将自己生活的哪些切面，在什么情境下，向什么人披露的权利。
[S01] 呃，我还是有点抽象。
[S02] 我举个例子吧，一位患有特定慢性病的用户，他可能非常愿意把自己的健康数据匿名共享给医疗研究机构，帮助科学家寻找疗法。
[S01] 这很好啊，造福人类。
[S02] 但他绝对不希望这些数据被流转到他的雇主或者保险公司手里。
[S01] 啊，因为那可能导致他失去晋升机会，或者面临天价保费。
[S02] 没错，隐私是你对自我边界的掌控，而当下的监视资本主义，恰恰是把这种决策权从你个人手中大规模剥夺，集中到了追求利润最大化的公司系统里。
[S01] 他们来决定你的数字轮廓可以被卖给谁。
[S02] 完全不受你的控制。
[S01] 顺着这个逻辑就引出了书里一个非常有颠覆性的观点。我们平时总听人吹捧说，数据是新时代的石油，仿佛只要去开采，就能带来无尽的财富。
[S02] 这是一个很大的误区。
[S01] 对，实际上石油是可以被消耗掉的，烧完就没了。
[S02] 书里提出，数据根本不是新石油，数据其实是新油矿。
[S01] 新油矿，这个比喻可以说是一针见血了。
[S02] 为什么是油矿呢？
[S01] 因为油矿虽然蕴藏着惊人的能量，但它具有可怕的半衰期，而且具有强烈的辐射性。
[S02] 这就是问题的关键。十年前你随手发的一条动态，点过的一个赞，甚至你每天通行的地理位置坐标并没有随着时间消失。
[S01] 它们被存放在云端的服务器里。
[S02] 就像被封存在铁桶里的放射性物质。
[S01] 随着AI分析工具变得越来越锐利，这些曾经看似无害的旧数据，随时可能被重新挖掘出来，拼凑出你不愿意示人的画像。
[S02] 而且你要知道，它也是一种随时可能引爆的有毒资产，或者叫危险材料。
[S01] 有毒资产。
[S02] 你想啊，你现在把数据交给了一家看起来很重视隐私的科技公司，但如果这家公司五年后破产了呢？
[S01] 数据会被打包卖掉。
[S02] 对，如果它被一家作风流氓的企业恶意收购了呢？甚至如果未来政局发生动荡，这些包含了你指纹、面部特征、家庭住址的数据库落入了不尊重人权的人手里，后果是不堪想象的。
[S01] 哇，这简直和工业革命早期的景象如出一辙。
[S02] 历史总是惊人的相似。
[S01] 当年蒸汽机和庞大的工厂确实带来了荆棘的狂飙突进，但代价是满天黑烟的雾霾，被毒水污染的河流，还有童工剥削。
[S02] 是的。
[S01] 现在的无底线数据收集，就像是当年工厂肆无忌惮地往河里排放工业废水一样。
[S02] 直到整个社会付出了极其惨痛的健康和环境代价，我们才建立起环保法规和劳动法。在今天的数字世界，这种摩擦同样剧烈。
[S01] 那我们要怎么治理这种数字污染呢？
[S02] 一方面是立法，一方面是自律。比如像GDPR这样的法规，在强力推行数据最小化原则，要求非必要不收集。
[S01] 但我猜阻力很大。
[S02] 阻力非常大，因为这和过去十年INTERNET大行其道的底层逻辑是存在着正面冲突的。
[S01] 聚族一节，技术架构上也会有冲突吗？
[S02] 冲突非常大。你看DDIA这本书，前面花了大量篇幅探讨的那些现代数据架构，比如事件溯源、不可变日志，或者像卡夫卡这样的消息队列。
[S01] 嗯，工程师都很熟悉。
[S02] 这些工程设计的核心哲学是保留一切历史，他们倾向于使用只能追加写入，也就是appendonly的数据结构。
[S01] 因为这样性能最好，对吧？
[S02] 对，而且如果系统出了故障，你可以随时回放历史数据来恢复状态。
[S01] 也就是所谓的大数据哲学，不管现在用不用得上，先统统存下来再说，收集尽可能多的数据。
[S02] 没错，所以当你作为一个用户要求根据法军彻底删除你的个人数据时，在现代的数据技术史里，这往往在工程上是一场噩梦。
[S01] 牵一发而动全身。
[S02] 是的，你要如何从一个分布式不可变的庞大日志流中精准地抽离并销毁属于某个特定用户的所有足迹，而不破坏整个系统的一致性，这非常困难。
[S01] 所以这不仅仅是一个法律问题，更是一个工程界的文化转型问题了。
[S02] 绝对的。工程师在设计系统的那一天起，就必须把如何干净利落地删除数据考虑进去，而不是把它当成一个麻烦的马后炮。
[S01] 毕竟最安全的办法就是不存在的数据就永远不会被泄露。
[S02] 这正是出路所在。科技行业必须进行一次根本的文化转向，停滞把用户仅仅看作仪表盘上可以被优化的指标。
[S01] 而是要把他们当成有尊严的，具体的人。
[S02] 我们需要从架构的基因里注入对人的尊重。
[S01] 谈到这里，我们也接近尾声了。今天我们穿透了数据架构信息型应用，那些关于一致性分片容错率的复杂技术术语，带你看到了数据驱动世界的另一面。
[S02] 代码有架构之外的深远影响。
[S01] 对，当你在感叹一个APP的响应速度有多快，推荐算法有多精准的时候，别忘了，这一切不仅关乎性能，更关乎权力的转移，公平、责任以及我们个人的控制权。
[S02] 了解这些底层逻辑，你就拥有了审视技术权利的觉悟。
[S01] 没错，作为数字时代的居民，这是重新夺回你对自身生活主导权的第一步。在我们结束之前，我想留给你一个延伸的思考。
[S02] 嗯，这也是我非常期待的部分。
[S01] 我们刚才聊到数据是新油矿，它有着惊人的半衰期和辐射危险。那么在未来的数字社会，当我们面对海量的带有你数字DNA的历史数据时，我们是否也需要建立一种类似数字核废料处理厂的机制？
[S02] 这是一个绝妙的概念。
[S01] 想想看，当你退出一项使用了十年的网络服务，或者当一家收集了你大量生物特种的初创公司倒闭时，究竟该由谁来负责安全地、永久地降解属于你的那部分数字和废料？
[S02] 这是一个巨大的真空地带。
[S01] 我们必须要确保它永远不会在几十年后突然辐射并反噬你的生活。这个问题留给你在下线后慢慢品味。感谢你加入今天的深入探讨，我们下次再见。